I know you're an amazing mom but are you
would you say that you are a kind of a
disciplinarian when it comes to being a
mom are you strict are you kind of
easygoing well I don't know I guess I'm
kind of strict about stuff but it's kind
of funny once you start to have
teenagers they become more adults and
you have these kind of relationships
that emerge with them and I just kind of
communicate with them in funny ways like
I said my daughter said the other day
she's like it's like we look like dad
but we got our weirdness from you but
I'm goofy I send them like weird
snapchats of me doing you know boys
movie teeth and that's the way we
communicate your tech savvy then cuz I'm
not I am NOT I'm not good at
snapchatting them or communicating in
any way i old-fashioned put notes on
parchment no I talked to them on the
devices they use is there on social
media all the time and I said my son I
like to like haunt him during the day so
I send him just pictures of disgusting
animals and be like I'm feeling like
this today like like if you ever seen a
blobfish
of you I think you posted this do we
notice a lot I think you posted this one
yeah I think you sent this very
disappointed that bit like Monday feels
or something like that like a blobfish
or I do like I'm there's like giant
massive snails that people put on their
faces have you seen that yes yeah I just
try to grow some out wait so you're just
blasting that stuff to your kids all day
long all day yeah non-stop yeah just so
they remember who's the weird one yeah
now are you still capable you're the
weird one I think I'm guessing you're
the fun one can you also drop the hammer
when it's time to get tough can you can
you yeah I mean I have like I'm
definitely like a southern mom like ice
done never lost the Tennessee and me and
the Tennessee is like we you kind of
like when you get really mad I get
really southern and then they if I get
real if I get kind of mad I'll give you
a sit to which just means you have to
sit down listen everything I have to say
and then if you really make me mad then
I give you what for this is a whole
other thing you don't want to get
involved
yeah we don't even have we didn't have
that language growing up a what for a
weapon yeah any of my dog versus the
other day like she's born in California
but she said you know and I gave that
person to sit to and I told them what
for it's seeping in I'm delighted
you